[Música]
bienvenidos y bienvenidas al espacio de
cultura de france 24 abrimos este
programa con la segunda temporada en la
plataforma prime vídeo de una serie está
evidente que mezcla drama adolescentes y
superviviencia de wilde salvajes en la
primera temporada un grupo de chicas se
encontraba varado en una isla remota sin
saber que se había convertido en el
objeto de un experimento social y en los
nuevos episodios aprendemos que un grupo
de chicos vivió lo mismo la trama de su
wire se lograba mantenernos en suspenso
gracias sobre todo a las excelentes
actrices y por la manera de narrar la
historia tras adentrarse en el pasado el
presente y el futuro de cada uno de los
personajes en un hermoso baile que
revela las capas y los misterios a cada
paso veamos el tráiler lynch
y es que el desastre
no cuestionen
[Música]
del lado del cine se estrenó la segunda
película centrada en las aventuras del
héroe de marvel doctor strange
reencontramos el neurocirujano y mago
super potente interpretado por el genial
benedict cumberbatch pero detrás de la
avalancha de efectos especiales que
ahora siempre acompañan este tipo de
superproducciones se nota la esencia y
la firma de su director sam raimi y
conocido por sus filmes de terror
[Aplausos]
y si aquí hablamos regularmente de las
grandes producciones de ficción también
queremos destacar los documentales que
pueden verse en gran pantalla como el
dirigido por el periodista francés luv
coche trincheras en español estas
trincheras son las del conflicto del
doom base en 2020 antes de la invasión
en ucrania por parte de rusia lujo pasó
cuatro meses allá para afirmar la vida
cotidiana de los soldados ucranianos que
desde 2014 se oponen a los separatistas
pro rusos y a las fuerzas de moscú todo
en blanco y negro lo que produce un
paralelismo directo con los conflictos
de principios del siglo 20 esto es lo
que lo unió retuvo de su rodaje en el
donbass es interesante porque encontré
las mismas cosas que se podían leer en
las cartas de los soldados franceses
durante la primera guerra mundial es
decir en las trincheras pasan mucho
tiempo también para matar el
aburrimiento para esperar y luego de
repente puede ocurrir un bombardeo y
entonces estás en peligro de muerte
directamente y de hecho es esta
ambivalencia esta paradoja de la
tranquilidad que se siente de una
normalidad de la vida cotidiana que los
soldados intentan crear con el peligro
que siempre está ahí y que ataca en
cualquier momento lo que me pareció
especialmente fuerte e interesante de
mostrar la documentación de los
conflictos pasa también por las fotos y
nos quedamos en ucrania con el trabajo
de periodistas de guerra cubriendo la
inversión rusa desde febrero el centro
cultural de la embajada de ucrania en
parís destaca actualmente las obras de
los fotógrafos ucranianos que han
permanecido en su país a pesar de la
guerra la exposición se llama los
indomables muestra incluso fotos tomadas
hace apenas unas semanas y rinde
homenaje a estos artistas y periodistas
que arriesgan sus vidas en el terreno
[Música]
en berlín son combatientes de otra época
que el público puede descubrir la
capital alemana acoge desde este mes el
primer museo dedicado al arte ya la
cultura samurai de europa que alberga
más de 1000 piezas incluyendo armaduras
espadas y mascarillas es un recorrido
por más de 1000 años de historia y
cultura nipona da en un espacio que
apuesta también por la tecnología
audiovisual para una experiencia
multimedia
hablamos ahora de una de las noticias
culturales más impactantes de la semana
la salida muy esperada del nuevo álbum a
the bad venís el puertorriqueño estrenó
un verano sin ti y su quinto disco de
estudio son 23 canciones que testifican
la exploración musical de badrán y con
temas letras ambientes y colaboraciones
bien diferentes entre ellas es un álbum
que sorprende y que no nos deja en la
cabeza unos estribillos muy pegadizos
ideal para las reuniones o fiestas del
verano
todo donde el lugar
vamos por cuanto 4
otro quinto muy esperado que se estrena
este viernes 13 de mayo mister magoo en
the big sisters del rapero
estadounidense que en reclamar no había
lanzado un tema desde 2018 año en el que
también se convirtió en el primer
artista de hip hop en recibir un premio
pulitzer y quien reclamó estreno hace
unos días el impresionante videoclip del
corazón party 5 donde utiliza la técnica
del more cine para cambiar su cara por
las de afroamericanos famosos
[Música]
nos despedimos con un condition look y
de la nueva canción del grupo de rock
independiente canadiense
fire una oda al amor incondicional
gracias por su confianza y cuídense
[Música]
tete a tete
este tipo
[Música]